hey man I think you should know that I  saw your wife with another man did they  have leftovers what did they have a bag  of food yes who  was holding  the bag she was  yeah now I have to say I think great  exception to the fact this is a bearded  man to see a bearded man cuckolding  himself like this is extremely  discouraging to me uh it brings shame on  the whole community of beardsman I hate  so much about the things that you choose  to be of course the cuckold effect  um kind of he affects this ironic  detached pose unconcerned that his wife  is being sexually satisfied by another  man  all he cares about is The Leftovers get  it he's not he's not a lame jealous  cuckold he's a cool sarcastic one that  makes it all better